to get this shot in 2022's bullet train
Brad Pitt was attached to a wire rig
capable of rotating him 360 Degrees
while this green suit performer safely
controlled his movements paired with
this wind machine the VFX team could
integrate him naturally into these
slow-mo shots of the train mid Blast
from performing risky stunts in the air
and at Sea to pushing car chases to new
heights here's what 12 2022 movies
looked like behind the scenes
for top gun Maverick Tom Cruise wanted
to send himself and the rest of the cast
up in real fighter jets but first they
had to go through an intense five-month
flying boot camp taught by none other
than Tom himself this ranged from
learning how to withstand High GS to
escaping an underwater plane crash the
cast started training in single-engine
Cessna 172 Skyhawks before building up
to the more aerobatic extra 300 and an
l-39 albatross got them used to the more
complex Maneuvers they'd be doing on
camera the result realistic facial
contortions like this
Tom really was launched off the USS
Theodore Roosevelt in an fa-18 he
accomplished this shot normally reserved
for Naval aviators in four to five takes
to capture all the action and reactions
of the actors the crew had to put
cameras everywhere they captured the
exterior shots on the ground as well as
from these camera planes following all
the action from above they also put six
cameras capable of capturing IMAX
footage in each cockpit because space
was tight the cameras had to be small
and each one could also be split apart
allowing the crew to detach the lens
from the body and capture a variety of
angles
Amazon there you go
to safely achieve this dangerous car
chase in the Batman the stunt team
decided to split it up filming it in
several separate locations they shot the
riskiest Parts on a half mile stretch of
highway allowing them to film 100
Vehicles swerving and hydroplaning and
this Stunt Driver was able to drive the
Batmobile through a real explosion
for action shots where Robert Pattinson
and Colin Farrell were visible the
actors hopped into these Hub cars where
mounted cameras captured them in the
driver's seat while a stunt person
operated the car from above but the
secret to tying it all together these
led screens
seven cameras captured the stunt team's
real driving footage which then played
on this 360 degree screen the Batmobile
and the Penguin's car were placed on
moving Platforms in front for realistic
movements while the LED screens provided
realistic lighting and reflections
Tom Holland described the stunts in this
scene from Uncharted as the most
difficult of his career the team broke
the action down into several parts when
Tom's character first falls out of the
plane they shot the sequence vertically
to better simulate falling through the
air they attached the crates to these
giant robotic arms which moved the boxes
back and forth while Tom was safely
secured to these wires when Tom climbs
back into the plane they placed the
boxes horizontally to allow him to more
easily jump from crate to Crate and this
car isn't real the front section was
attached to a rig to pull it forward and
the stand-in was later replaced with a
CG model Tom was attached to a set of
wires to both pull him forward and keep
him horizontal
yeah
Rising Sun Pictures worked on over 300
visual effects shots for the latest Thor
movie love and thunder including a giant
God and a battling baby outlandish
scenarios like these required fully
digital doubles in this shot the
gigantic rapu was standing on a platform
while Gore played by Christian Bale was
lifted up by this tuning fork to make it
look like rapu had him in a Chokehold
animators replaced robu with a fully
digital double for greater control but
they mapped the actor's real face onto
the digital body to keep his performance
intact they did a similar replacement
for Gore on set Christian was held up on
his back by replacing the angle of his
body it would look more like the
character was actually being held up by
his neck and baby Thor is based on a
real infant Rising Sun Pictures fed
reference photos and Behavior videos
into a machine learning pipeline so
while baby Thor's look and movements
were animated they were directly derived
from real references making it seem even
more lifelike
in Multiverse of Madness Dr Strange and
Scarlet Witch Battle while flying or
floating so Elizabeth Olsen and Benedict
Cumberbatch along with their stunt
doubles had to be ready for some intense
wire work like here when Wanda launches
herself backwards during the Illuminati
fight stunt double CC ice was attached
to a backwards flying ratchet this setup
required strong core engagement
mid-flight so she wouldn't fall forward
or backward during the ascent and
descent
and by rehearsing it enough to get the
timing right she could land in the right
spot without looking the setup changed
for the aftermath of this floor
explosion this time CeCe was on a half
wrap meaning the cable was partially
wrapped around her body while also
attached to her harness that way once
the ratchet was activated CeCe would
spin around before hitting the floor but
certain wire setups worked for multiple
situations the crew filmed this flying
stunt horizontally however they filmed
it in front of a green screen meaning
they could also use it as a vertical
takeoff from the ground but for the
comfort and safety of the actors
sometimes a tuning fork worked better in
the Final Shots they were either locked
in place with a harness or put into this
twisting ring that let them Spin and
flip while attached to the fork great
for mid-air fight scenes
the crew of Jordan Peel's nope built the
Haywood ranch house from scratch over a
period of 10 weeks during filming it
would also have to be drenched in blood
to achieve these terrifying shots the
special effects team took rain bars used
to create movie rain and filled them
with water that was dyed red that
created the look of bloody rain but it
would wash away too quickly to show the
lasting damage of the blood production
designer Ruth Deon sprayed the house
with a non-toxic oil mixture she first
used on There Will Be Blood that would
soak naturally into its surroundings the
crew even strapped objects like an ice
cream machine to the roof to represent
the aftermath of the aliens attack
thank you
for this Unforgettable storm sequence on
a luxury yacht in Triangle of sadness
all that turbulence was really happening
in camera thanks to these gimbals under
the sets the base could only hold around
12 000 pounds so the boat Interiors had
to be split into two separate sets one
with the hallway and bedrooms and
another with the dining room the steel
base holding the set was placed on a
gimbal that was capable of tilting the
set from side to side
to find the right amount of movement to
mimic a storm the team tested several
motions with objects and crew members
according to Panorama sfx's Matthias
Jensen they started by tilting the boat
from zero to 1.5 degrees as the storm
picked up all the way up to 13 degrees
making everything from the chairs to
wine glasses to the food on this plate
shape and while the moving sets were
filmed in front of a blue screen the
water you see splashing on the Windows
was real the crew member you see here
had to always spray in the correct
direction based on the boat's forward
movement as the storm got worse Panorama
had to do some extra work
like placing an air cannon under this
exploding toilet and mixing 2 000 liters
of water with soy sauce and oatmeal to
get the right color and texture once the
boat starts flooding the rocking sets
were so effective that some of the crew
actually got seasick
spite scenes raised the stakes by using
everyday objects As Weapons which were
specially designed and rigged by the
props Department like this keyboard the
props team cut a hole in it in advance
covered it with a piece of cardstock and
then glued all the keys back on so this
pipe could easily go through it for
others like this riot shield used by
Michelle yo They removed these small
pieces of exposed metal same went for
all the zippers and buckles on kihi
Quan's deadly fanny pack which they
covered in foam but the fights went far
beyond that the cast members had to go
through wushu and nunchuck training and
in tribute to wirefu Jamie Lee Curtis
performed a flying knee move here and
Michelle looked like she was delivering
major blows with just one pinky
foreign
Moon fall employed wind machines flooded
sets and fake snow
but director Roland emmerich had to go
far beyond that like pulling the actors
on wires to account for the Earth's
changing gravitational pull as the moon
approaches but the biggest challenge
this avalanche-based car chase this
involved a combination of special
effects and VFX Wizardry while the wide
shots would always be CG they also
needed shots at the actors in The Cars
so the special effects team built these
hovercraft-like platforms for each car
controlled either by hand or by
Hydraulics these let them safely slide
float drift and crash into each other
all that action was captured by cameras
attached to these three axis cranes that
way the action could be more effectively
integrated into the wider CG shots
to create the illusion of a real moving
train for bullet train the crew built
two different detached cars on a Sound
Stage to represent different sections
when a train needed to pull up at a
station the cars were attached and
placed onto a pulley system the legs
released air pressure against the floor
allowing the cars to slide easily
additionally each car's walls could come
down allowing the crew to easily move
around the interior and to film fight
scenes to add the illusion of movement
the VFX team shot real footage of
landscapes in Japan and then sped it up
and projected it on these led screens
the crew also filmed overhead footage
from drones VFX artists could then
seamlessly place the CG train and tracks
into those shots
foreign
most action movies use as many cameras
as possible the northmen made the
unusual decision to use just one
that meant fewer Cuts during action in
the one take Berserker battle the cast
and crew had way less room for error in
all the foreground and background action
ninety percent of the movie had to be
storyboarded and pre-planned with a
smaller model of the village the stunts
were also planned around the camera's
path which would move from cranes to
Pursuit vehicles to boats one way to
sell this whole illusion hidden camera
edits known as stitches which disguise
the edits in the scene
you can see one here as the camera
swings onto the Viking ship you can see
one of the cast members ducking the
camera's path right here the raid itself
contained only four stitches including
this one when Alexander skarsgard's
character skills a high wall and another
at this brutal Stomp
to properly bring Elvis's story to life
director baz luhrmann built accurate
replicas of Graceland and Beale Street
and even acquired 300 cars and
motorcycles to stand in for Elvis's
famed collection and while actor Austin
Butler went through over 90 costume
changes that wouldn't make a difference
if he couldn't imitate Elvis's iconic
moves so he worked with movement coach
Paulie Bennett to help him really embody
and nail the moves Paulie had Austin
study references Beyond concert footage
like animals and specifically their eye
movements they studied alligators
emerging from the water and scoping out
their terrain and cats to mimic the
cat-like eye movements they saw in the
king selling the performance meant also
working on the reactions
so Paulie coached these Elvis super fans
known as the scream Queens she rehearsed
with them until they got their
exaggerated arm waving body shaking and
screams down
oh
my God